the jurgen experience i thought about
you two weeks ago
when i went to cvs and i saw a white guy
and a hot african-american chick having
an argument outside of cvs
at 9 20 in the morning he was a little
chubby
and they were having some type of loud
discussion i went and i got my
medication when i walked out
he's yelling that i want my wallet back
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why'd you think of me
so this is how bad it is where i live
now so
this is my cvs this is the main one i've
been going to
for 10 years and also when i walk out
i walk towards my car but i hear him go
i want my [ __ ] wallet back
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and she's like i
didn't take your wallet
and what are you going to do call the
police and tell them what i sucked your
dick is that
not a wedding ring around your hand
and he goes [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] if
it's a wedding ring give me my [ __ ]
wallet and he hauls off and smacks the
dexa like [ __ ]
name a knockout in the ufc this is way
better than anything you've ever seen
the [ __ ] pimp was down the block he
took off on his [ __ ] car
the wallet fell out of her bra people
ran to him
me i didn't have a piece so i got in my
car and took off because it's a lot of
shooting in
north hollywood lately two days [ __ ]
later
i'm at the office i go let me go check
on the office get some [ __ ] out of there
i go down the block i go down [ __ ]
whatever and i hook on lancashire
i'm stuck by the train station i'm the
third car
in uh the inside lane
so i'm going south down lancashire okay
i'm about to hit
magnolia the federal all that stuff
but i'm sitting right there crossing the
train station
and all of a sudden out of the left of
my eye
i see this commotion and i see this
woman looking up
and all of a sudden i see an axe handle
or something hit her
and she goes down into the street and
it's a white guy
with a vest on just hitting people with
axe handles
and they're going down one by one jesus
all of a sudden
i see a chubby guy running across the
street
and [ __ ] he starts chasing the chubby
guy traffic is beeping
beep beep beep it's 3 30 in the
afternoon and also i go this is my
chance to be a [ __ ] hero
i hook a u-turn and i'm going to shoot
down the street
and catch him at the end and hit him
with my car it's been years
since i hit a [ __ ] with my car
when i get to the corner i hit the
[ __ ] left
the guy sees me he dropped the axe
handle already
he sees me and he runs left instead of
right if he would have ran
right i would have just hit him with the
car and kept going it would have been an
accident
i didn't see him he committed a crime he
dropped the axe hand on the guy was on
the floor
and his head was bleeding and then the
guy ran back to the train station
to get some more what is happening
that's why i'm leaving
[ __ ] lancashire man lancashire is
[ __ ] nuts
my girl calls me my my dog she's married
she's my buddy she's like i had a rough
day on the set can i talk to you i'll
meet you behind the y like i usually
meet you
let's smoke a number we socially
distance
she sits in her car and i sit in my car
and she tells me about a day on the set
and it's 10 after 9 because i got to
catch it before mercy goes to sleep
so i mean like a quarter to nine we're
talking and also when you hear
ba ba ba
and then you hear papa right behind them
we're like did you [ __ ] hear that
that was right on the [ __ ] corner i
go home my wife goes thank god you're
home
she goes it's all over the place there
was a shooting
at magnolia lancashire she goes to drive
by and then the guy they shot at shot
twice that chicken place is there
there's a chicken place i said hot
chicken hot chicken
hot dave's hot chicken yeah dog it's not
bueno by me though
it's not blended by a lot of people so
the axe handle just came out of nowhere
and hit this lady in the head i was
sitting there
in my own business this guy came out of
the crate
so we stopped bueno you're seeing more i
see i went i go to burbank a lot and i
go down magnolia they've been saying
that about new york two random people
getting sucker punched
new york and chicago are both really bad
right now
valley village park a guy was walking
this dog at two in the morning four
identified men jumped out of a car and
threw a beating on him
i don't want what's in seattle and
portland to come down here and catch
my wife had to go downtown the idea to
send money
and she goes downtown it's just horrible
it's already
horrible to begin with but it's it's
nightmare now you have stayed up here
and up there
your final conclusion is to get in the
car one day next week i've told you
and just go say your goodbyes to the
calm you start by yourself you don't
have to bring nobody
put your hand on the wall make a left
only sienna
and then pick a street and make a left
so you can make another left to get on
the one-on-one
and make a mental projection of when
this will come back
but you know what everybody wanted the
zombie apocalypse
you got it [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you want everybody
i'm a zombie it's pretty close
[Applause]